israel has been praised for the progress
it's been making in vaccinate
vaccinating its population the
government says it hopes every israeli
citizen will have been inoculated by the
end of march
but prime minister benjamin netanyahu is
also facing flack for failing to
organize supplies of the vaccine for
some
five million palestinians living in the
occupied territories
critics say they have been left to fend
for themselves dw's tanya kramer reports
a covet 19 testing center in the west
bank town of ramallah
the infection rates in the occupied
palestinian territories have been high
in recent months
so far people here have had to wait for
any vaccinations
while enabling israel the vaccination
drive has taken off quickly
human rights groups have criticized
israel for not helping to finance
or supply vaccines to palestinians
but this week the palestinian government
announced that it had secured vaccines
from
several companies the health ministry
signed an agreement with four companies
to import vaccines the shipments will
arrive
during the coming two months we will
start vaccinating the medical teams old
residents
patients until we vaccinate 70 percent
of the residents in the west bank
gaza and jerusalem
the prospect of the arrival of a vaccine
has been welcomed
albeit with some reservations
we want all of us to take it to feel
psychologically at ease because we are
in a constant state of worry
but they want to bring the russian
vaccine and we do not have much faith in
the russian vaccine
at the end i hope we will get the
appropriate vaccine
and we will be done with this crisis
because it has affected
all the sectors in this country
but they will have other options the
palestinians have also signed up to the
kovacs program in partnership with the
world health organization it aims to
help
low-income countries to get a fair share
of vaccines
for around 20 percent of their
population
gerald rockenshield heads the world
health organizations office for the
palestinian territories and he joins me
now from jerusalem
dr rock and chav how dire is the
situation in the palestinian territories
at the moment
well you know equitable access to corona
vaccines
is a challenge globally but you know the
inequity
probably is nowhere as visible as it is
in the israeli-palestinian context
with 2 million israelis having been
vaccinated so far
but no palestinians except for those
residing in east jerusalem
well exactly that was going to be my
next question i mean israel has already
vaccinated more than
20 of its population why have the
palestinian territories
been left behind
part is because there are global
shortages of vaccines and there is a lot
of competition that's why this
kovacs facility was created to ensure
that also those countries who can't get
vaccines on the free global market
get their fair share of the vaccines and
we're working with the ministry of
health very closely
to ensure that all the preparations are
in place to
receive vaccines through this covax
facility hopefully during the first
quarter of the year
why has it been specifically hard for
the palestinian territories to get
access to the vaccine then if
israel hasn't had such a problem
well i mean these raid is procured at
the global market they entered
agreements with private companies uh
the palestinians had some challenges in
that respect
they are primarily relying on the kovacs
facility but they're also exploring
other channels
there are discussions with with russia
with china
also with private companies but also
other countries
frankly have difficulties uh to mobilize
the adequate
quantities of vaccines at the moment
well i mean there has been a push by
some rich nations for an equitable
distribution and you talk about the
kovacs
strategy um even though
we're seeing it play out here are poorer
nations
losing out
well for us it's primarily a public
health and an equity concern so we also
have some consultation
with israeli counterparts and in our
meetings we have flake that there are a
number of good public health reasons
for israel to support the vaccination
efforts on the palestinian
side potentially even to allocate some
vaccine supplies
from from their supplies particularly to
target the health workforce in palestine
well israeli the israeli prime minister
has said that israel wants to help its
neighbours are there any concrete plans
of how that might look
yeah i mean we have very good
discussions uh with with kogat
the military administration also with
ministry of health
technical people just to ensure that all
the coordination mechanisms are in place
that customs clearance processes
don't create any obstacles once the
vaccines start to arrive through the
kovacs facility
or through other channels and then all
the preparatory efforts
and national vaccine deployment plan
code chain assessments and so forth
are in place all right gerald rockenshaw
head of the world health organization
office for the palestinian territories
thanks very much for your time
thanks very much